hi this is derek stevens i'm the owner  of circle las vegas  it was just a few months ago that i said  our hotel would open no later  than december 28th well our guys did a  great job  and we're going to open december 28th  but we do have something special in  store  everyone that books with us for our  opening night we're gonna allow them to  check in early the world's earliest  check-in  you can check in as early as 3 p.m on  saturday  december 26th so basically the first  couple days are on us  it's going to take us a little while to  check everybody in seeing us we've never  done it before  book with us at circa las vegas dot com  can't wait to see everybody just before  new year